hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my spider-man homecoming villain for
all the deep cuts villains they're gonna
include from the comics so here we go so
most of you probably know that this is
largely going to be a high school
franchise Harry Potter style we're going
to follow a Peter Parker through his
sophomore junior and senior years of
high school so the homecoming title is
very appropriate for a number of
different reasons you know largely
because he's come home to marvel in the
cinematic universe but also because
homecoming is a big idea in the context
of high school itself so one of the
other big things that they've done as
they bring spider-man home is take the
series all the way back to the beginning
of the spider-man comics and when you
hear about some of the villains that
they're doing it'll totally make sense
so one we know about vulture being in
the movie he was one of the earliest big
spider-man villains but some of the
other people in the movie are way deeper
cuts like Jacob battle on the actor
who's playing one of Peter Parker's
friends in high school he appeared in
classroom scenes with Peter Parker in
the comic-con trailer his name is Ned
Leeds in most of you when you hear that
name Ned leaves your ears will prick up
a little bit and you go like wait a
minute Peter's friend in high school is
Hobgoblin Ned Leeds was Hobgoblin in the
comics so huge deep cut obviously this
high school kid is probably not going to
turn into Hobgoblin during this movie
but you can see how they're seeding the
universe and going way way back to the
earliest spider-man comics and it also
seems like based on some of the stuff
that beau Keene woodbine was doing in
the trail like he and a couple of the
people were robbing a store it seems
like they're doing the enforcers which
was one of the earliest villain team ups
in the spider-man comics so if you
haven't read a lot of the earliest
spider-man Steve Ditko spider-man
stories a lot of the stories were
written like crime thrillers so
naturally mobsters played a big role in
that the enforcers were just kind of
like an earlier proto
of the sinister six made up of mobsters
so like the enforcers debut then much
much later in like the first big
spider-man annual they have a big
villain team-up that becomes the
sinister six so it's like in the Batman
comics like you meet the Joker you meet
these other characters but Batman's
mostly fighting mobsters it's a lot of
crime drama but eventually the Batman
comics work up to injustice society big
justice league level stories so it's
kind of the same thing with the
spider-man comics even like the
for Nolan Batman movies did this to
where Batman faces mobsters first Danny
works his way up to crazy supervillains
so it seems like there's going to be
some of that going on during spider-man
homecoming so they're invoking a lot of
the classic comics and they're giving
you a nice balance of street-level
villains for spider-man to fight as well
as like the really big comic book deep
cups like vulture so here is where it
really gets crazy if you guys aren't
excited for spider-man already think
about it this way the enforcers are a
team of hired goons essentially they get
hired by other super criminals in the
universe namely Norman Osborn and I know
a lot of you were like hey how come
vultures the big villain of the movie
why isn't Green Goblin the villain of
the movie well they said that in doing
this new spider-man trilogy and it will
be a trilogy if that wasn't clear I know
they've only announced spider-man
homecoming there will totally be a
trilogy they said that in doing
spider-man I get like be you know
because of all the stuff that's happened
all the drama behind the scenes they
just want to start fresh and do
something with the character that's
never been done on-screen and that
involves doing villains that they have
not done in the comics yet so that's why
a lot of the characters the villains the
friends will be a little bit different
than the ones that you've seen in
previous spider-man movies so the other
big question that everyone has is is
because spider-man is street-level in
New York I mean he's an Avenger so he's
kind of a combination of like the big
Avengers level characters like the big
a-list superheroes that you see in the
movies all the time in the street-level
heroes that you see in the Netflix shows
so when it makes sense that spider-man
would bump into the defenders at some
point well we know that kingpin is one
of the big crime bosses of New York he's
going to get out of prison soon he has
been connected to the enforcers like I
said who are going to be villains in the
spider-man movie we've seen them show up
in the daredevil comics so a lot of the
lesser characters that you see in the
spider-man movie are shared daredevil
characters so there's your connection to
the Netflix shows right there like
kingpin big spider-man villain but also
one of the big bads of the daredevil
Netflix universe so while I'm not
expecting to see Tom Holland appear in
defenders or any of those shows I think
that you'll see a lot of Ant Man style
references to a guy that wears a red
costume and crawls up walls because the
easy joke to make and I've heard rumors
that there's a joke about this about
people confusing daredevil with
spider-man like oh thank you for saving
me
daredevil and spider-mans like that's
not that's not me that's another guy or
vice versa with daredevil being like I'm
not the guy that crawls the walls I'm a
totally different guy so here's my big
question for you guys given that we're
seeing a lot of shared daredevil
spider-man villains in the spider-man
movie how do you want to see those two
characters cross over eventually I know
a lot of people want to see the Netflix
people in Avengers infinity war that
hasn't been confirmed yet Robert Downey
jr. Facebook account posted this picture
but the problem with that is that it's
fan-made because you see all these
defenders characters appear on here and
right now they're shooting defenders in
New York City and they're working on
Avengers infinity war in Atlanta and
this is the old logo they've already
changed the titles of both of these
infinity war movies so a lot of you this
morning we're just asking me about this
and know you know what happens is is
that Robert Downey jr. doesn't operate
his Facebook account so when you see him
posting stuff that's not Robert Downey
jr. posting things
it's his intern posting things so just
keep that in mind whenever you're
wondering you know whether or not an
actor is posting something spoilery for
one of the movies but spider-man stuff I
know everybody's gonna like walk away
from this video being like wait a minute
if Norman Osborn hires the enforcers
there in the first movie does that mean
we're going to see Green Goblin in the
second movie or the third movie and if
Hobgoblin is his friend in high school
does that mean we're going to see
Hobgoblin in the movies too I think
there are a number of things that could
totally end up happening a lot of it
just depends on the creative decisions
that they make down the road so like
Kevin Feige and all like all the people
that are working on these films they're
laying groundwork they're planting seeds
for a whole bunch of stuff that might
grow into actual stories but as is the
case with any big movie like even
Captain America Civil War there are a
number of different things that could
happen just depending on stuff behind
the scenes actors contracts things that
might not work out like they originally
had a different plan for Captain America
Civil War if they were not going to be
able to use spider-man but the deal
worked out so they were able to use the
story that they wanted to do but they
had a number of different plans
depending on whether or not that worked
out so it's the same deal with the rest
of the spider-man movies with all the
movies in general even infinity war the
really really big stuff so let me know
in the comments how long do you think
it's going to be before we see daredevil
and spider-man on screen together in how
long before we see Wolverine in
spider-man
and on-screen together one of those will
definitely happen before the others but
in case you guys didn't know there's new
round of the Marvel giveaway this week
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
so let me know in the comments if
there's any Marvel videos that you guys
want me to do in the next couple days
later tonight I'm going to be working on
a new bit you know flash Supergirl
Justice League TV crossover video they
put like Stephen Amell just dropped this
picture and you can't tell from the
sound of my voice that I was making like
the Deadpool what gasp face like oh my
god it's happening but it's a little
early in the year so I'll explain when I
post that video tonight so flash season
Supergirl season 2 all that stuff coming
tonight where you guys wait for that
video to post you can click here to
learn all about the iron spider suit in
spider-man homecoming the stark tech
suit and you can click here for all my
Suicide Squad movie Easter eggs thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight